chara brice dans la vie normale comme
vous dites il y a le mot la vie la vie
voilà qui vous a éveillé la nuit grâce
voilà grâce au vaccin jusqu'à maintenant
ce qui est étonnant c'est que ce que tu
étais là quand j'entends fabrice di
vizio s'était rendu en temps le loup
y es ici y'a autant encore l'humanité
médecin qui change pour le ps en est
d'autres qui sont contre ailleurs on
avait ici quelqu'un qui était pour le
pass vaccinale c'est un infectiologue
c'est pas un débile mental qui était la
sedane infectiologues d'accord il m'a
avocat les médecins en quoi donc fait ce
que lui soit poupon alors la meilleure
et baradat match également jeudi que
c'est quoi ta me lâcher c'est par un nul
1-1 et légumes qui sont d'ordre qui sont
contre et leur or justement des macros
cantonales ou n'importe où c'est
d'entendre toutes les voies et de madrid
et si j en deux minutes le ciel fut
le mec il ya deux personnes en face ça
s'appelle un débat il pense que tu as 50
50 de la population
mais tu sais pas s'il faut jamais
accuser n'importe quoi qui est celle de
n'importe quoi j'ai mes os oui sortez
d'où aux chiffres datent de
mai non mais je sais pas c'est vous qui
donnait sa yamaha débat
section des deux bah oui ah oui mais
alors aimer les deux savaient alors j'ai
enfin c'est normal ça tue le débat est
alors été importe quoi à cheikh cissé
est alors gardons je vais plus prospère
c'est un infectiologue ce docteur enric
elysées ce que des charmantes et nos
colonnes
m
[Rires]
je vais des pertes racines ou alors on a
un rapport je me demandais si j'allais
donner des chiffres on a un rapport de
l'université d'amsterdam alors que je
peux te donner merci qu'à travailler
soit pas sanitaires sur six mois qui
s'est demandé est-ce que ça permettait
de lutter contre l'épidémie réponse non
non ça on en est sûr est-ce qu
effectivement ça a permis d'éviter des
réalisations renonce ou non non non non
c'est à dire qu'est ce que ça
économiquement mille pays dans une
situation compliquée réponse est oui
alors j'ai abandonné israël tant ibm
conclusions mais y a qu'en france où par
une opération divine on arrive à dire
que ça a sauvé quatre mille vies et
campus à doper le pib pour les fêtes les
ennemis vous êtes le désamour du combiné
ressort avec un truc qui sort du cac
rennes qui dit la vérité
[Musique]
là
ça passe et ça vient du jura que ça
vient du
massachusetts est victime le peuple
sommes donc dans le si d'ici là je vais
la lire
les rennais
[Rires]
n'ont
cessé de lire une foule y signer ces
contrats là donc ça veut dire
déboursant n'est qu'à 2 73 % des cas
quant au vide concerné personnes
vaccinées et plus de quatre personnes
de quatre personnes sur cinq est ce
normal
c'est le rêve de toute femme et
n'importe quoi je veux dire enfin le
céder face à martic ah oui j'abandonnais
j'ai les jambes
éduquer dézingue ça sert à rien quoi
je suis obsédé moi j'ai l'habitude de me
sacs des chevaux bakbasel
fabrice
15 % des gens qui ont l'air frais